[Musique]
il ya de l'aluminium dans les vaccins ça
fait super dangereux
bah non c'est toujours le même problème
en fait il ya des gens qui disent 'voilà
l'aluminium monde ira bien que ça
provoque des maladies musculaires et
derrière rien enfin si derrière on fait
des études des recherches pour vérifier
bon déjà des adjuvants à base
d'aluminium
il y en a dans quasiment tous les
vaccins ça me booste le système
immunitaire et ça rend le vaccin plus
efficace et alors donc les études disent
quoi ballon que oui il ya un plot
d'aluminium qui restent dans la zone où
on a fait l'injection mais que non rien
ne permet de dire que ça provoque des
malaises en fait les feld aluminium ils
sont utilisés depuis plus de 90 ans et
on vaccine des dizaines de millions de
personnes dans le monde entier
chaque année la fameuse balance bénéfice
risque elle est très nettement en faveur
du nombre de vies sauvées
surtout que le risque il a même pas été
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]